hey guys it's justine and today we are
unboxing the brand new apple tv
4k with the brand new redesigned apple
tv remote and when they announced this
twitter just lit up with how excited
people were about this new remote so
we're gonna get a chance to check it out
right now slice slice slice
check it out this does look very similar
to the previous version but this now
will support high frame rate hdr content
because the new iphone 12 does
shoot dolby vision hdr we'll be able to
play back that content on your new apple
tv 4k but let's take a look at this new
remote
look at you so they now have the siri
button right on the side this outer edge
is also
touch controlled so you can just kind of
scroll back and forth through your
content
and the buttons are very similar but it
just feels better it's a little bit
thicker
i feel like they should have integrated
air tags into this
so you'd be able to find my apple tv
remote because this is something that i
could never
ever find i do honestly just end up
using the remote that's built into my
iphone
i do love the look of this new
redesigned remote so i look forward to
testing this out after we get our apple
tv all synced up to our tv
one feature that i'm so excited to test
out is the color calibration
you can use your iphone to color
calibrate your apple tv
to get the best possible look so you're
just gonna hold your iphone up to the tv
and it's using the front-facing camera
to help calibrate to get you guys the
best look using your iphone
and the new apple tv 4k is there
anything else in the box
we've got a little usb to lightning
cable to charge
the remote a power cable and the hdmi
cable
is sold separately so that's the
unboxing i'm actually home visiting my
parents right now so we're gonna go to
my sister's house and get this all set
up and get her tv color calibrated
so i have the apple tv all set up and
one of the things that i love so much
about setting up new apple products is
they're so easy to configure
all i had to do was bring my phone close
to the apple tv and it basically set up
all of my settings for me i have been
traveling this past week i finally got a
chance to go home and visit my family
i'm fully vaxxed and i've been hanging
out with them all week so this
is actually my sister's little
television setup in her living room
and i have the apple tv all set up here
so we've been watching content i've been
doing apple fitness classes on this
because i do have of course my apple
watch
and that's one of the really cool things
about apple tv is you are able to
integrate with apple fitness if you do
have an apple watch
you can do your classes on the tv it'll
show all of your stats right up here
it'll connect directly to your apple
watch it's saying connect to apple tv
look at this
there it is connect to apple tv let's do
it i love even if i'm traveling i'm able
to take my fitness routines with me
using apple fitness
and i do actually use apple fitness a
lot i mostly do a lot of yoga classes
dustin is my favorite yoga instructor on
apple fitness so i've been doing a bunch
of his classes and looks like he has a
new hip-hop class
right here here's a little
to standing preview breath in your palms
dot jumper salute
hi i'm dustin all the poses in this
short
slow flow are done standing to help you
with these tightness in your shoulders
i do use apple fitness a lot on my ipad
when i'm at my gym at home but it really
is
incredible that you can do this on a big
television as well one thing to note
though
is this is an lg tv and it does have an
apple tv app built into it if you do
have one of those you aren't able to use
the apple fitness features to connect to
your apple watch you can only do that
with the standalone apple tvs
one feature that is really cool about
this new apple tv 4k
is the color calibration feature you're
able to use your front-facing iphone
camera to calibrate your television to
get the best color accuracy
we just go into video and audio scroll
down to color balance
and we're going to adjust the color
balance so it says apple tv will measure
and adjust your tv's color balance for
best results avoid bright or highly
saturated picture modes like vivid or
sport we're going to click continue to
connect
turn your phone around so the
front-facing camera is pointing at the
television
hold it centered in the outline and it's
supposed to be about an
inch from the screen so you can see that
these colors are popping up
and this is using the front-facing
camera to determine the
accuracy of the colors which is pretty
freaking cool and our color balance is
complete
now we're going to be able to get to see
these results now obviously i'm filming
this
on a camera so it's going to be kind of
hard for you guys to really see the
difference
unless you're actually seeing it in
person so this is what it looks like if
it's balanced
and here's the original okay you can see
look this has a much warmer color in the
sand
the greens are a little bit more vibrant
in the water
here's the original here's balanced
original
balanced we're gonna stay with a
balanced color this is really great for
a lot of tvs that don't have dolby atmos
or something similar built into it
this tv actually already does so the
color calibration on this tv is already
really good but it's kind of cool that
you're able to even dial that in
even further so if you have apple arcade
you can now connect the next gen
consoles to your apple tv and you can
use your controllers to play games in
apple arcade and this is pretty exciting
especially for those who
already have these consoles and you want
to connect a controller to it
you can where's my story time game oh
cozy grave grove that says grove
not cozy grave i'm really close to the
tv so it's kind of hard to read so
there's tons of games that you can play
on apple tv and of course you can listen
to music
i can say play slayer
now this is a hit no one can tell me
differently
i love that they have the lyrics up here
so you know just in case you want to
have a family sing-along to some slayer
you can
find me a comedy movie i actually just
watched this last night together
together it was good
but if anybody has seen it let me know
how you feel about the ending
so obviously it's apple tv so if you do
have a tv plus subscription
you'll be able to watch all this
wonderful apple tv content
this is next on my list that i want to
watch is billy eilish's documentary god
i freaking love billy eilish
freaking love her new controller is
really great you can actually use
touch gestures around this outer wheel
to go forward
or to go backwards when you're watching
content there's two new buttons we have
this button here which is the new power
button so you can turn your apple tv on
or off or it'll be able to control your
tv
and there's also a new mute button which
is very exciting because that's
something that they didn't have before
and of course the siri button has been
relocated
right there to the side and to charge it
just like before you've got your
lightning port here
i love the new remote so i just
downloaded the red bull app because they
have a special section here
that will take full advantage of using
the 4k
hdr high frame rate that is now
available on the new apple tv 4k so here
we have 4k
hdr content
look at these colors they are so
vibrant
looks really good something else that's
really great is the fact that now the
new iphone 12 does shoot high frame rate
hdr taking advantage of the dolby vision
hdr
and now that the level tv 4k supports
that you'll be able to play that content
directly on your television to get the
full effect
so basically you will have a full dolby
vision
4k hdr camera in your pocket well thank
you guys so much for watching i'm very
excited to continue testing this out
further i have a bunch of fun apple
videos that i posted this week so i'll
put those in the description so be sure
to check those out and subscribe for
more videos give this video a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it and hit the bell so
you'll be notified when i post new
videos
and with that my friends i will see you
in the next video
you